nous sommes en pleine crise du colis de
19 et si beaucoup de choses horribles
ont déjà eu lieu
il est malheureusement probable que le
pire soit encore devant nous en
particulier dans la dernière vidéo j'ai
insisté sur le rôle critique d'un nombre
appelé le taux de reproduction effectif
est habituellement nos trt ce nombre
mesure le nombre moyen d'individus
qu'une personne infectée à l'instant t
contaminera en particulier la valeur de
rt après le confinement aura très
probablement un effet majeur sur le
futur de nos sociétés
en bref si rt est inférieur à 1 alors le
kobe de 19 sera sous contrôle et tout
ira bien mais si rt est supérieur à 1
alors le comité 19 se propagera à
nouveau un rythme exponentiel
dès lors y compris selon certains
économistes il faudra imposer un second
confinement et personne ne veut sa pire
encore on a vu qu'un second confinement
augmenterait très probablement des
risques majeurs aussi bien d'un point de
vue sanitaire qu'économique ou politique
dans la vidéo précédente j'avais même
envisagé des cas extrêmes de guerre
civile ou internationales y compris dans
des pays développés même si ces cas
extrêmes sont peu probables
ils ne sont peut-être pas suffisamment
improbable pour être écartée ainsi dès à
présent il semble urgent de faire de
notre mieux pour maximiser autant que
possible la probabilité d'avoir rt
inférieure à 1
après confinement le futur de nos
sociétés semblent être en jeu
pour réduire erté on a tous énormément
de bonnes habitudes à prendre dès
aujourd'hui pour se préparer pour le
déconfinement vous en avez sans doute
déjà entendu parler mais vu l'urgence
actuelle je préfère les rappeler même si
vous n'avez pas de symptômes limitez vos
interactions sociales en présence
physique garder autant que possible au
moins deux mètres de distance entre vous
et d'autres élus au niveau des foules
lavez vous les mains ne touchez pas vos
visage avec les mains désinfectées
régulièrement ce que vous touchez en
particules vos téléphones et vos
ordinateurs
évitez de toucher les objets public tous
et dans votre coude ou dans un mouchoir
jetable pour l'instant il semble y avoir
des pénuries de masques dans certains
endroits
si c'est le cas pensez à laisser l'accès
à ce matériel à ceux qui en auront le
plus besoin
dans le cas contraire penser à acheter
et à porter des masques
ces masques ne réduiront peut-être pas
beaucoup votre probabilité d'être
infecté par le coronavirus mais il
semble réduire votre probabilité de le
transmettre
et ça c'est très important car réduire
rt est vraiment critique et surtout dès
que vous avez le moindre symptôme
restez chez vous pendant au moins une
semaine dix jours selon les agences
sanitaires suisses si possible ne
quittez pas votre habitation pendant
cette période même pour aller faire des
courses
ceci reste la meilleure façon de réduire
drastiquement la propagation du virus
donc pour vous préparer à ce risque de
quarantaine penser à faire des réserves
pour environ deux semaines pour éviter
de vider les magasins ce n'est pas
nécessaire de faire beaucoup plus
réservé que cela toutes ces
interventions ont un effet sur arte
cependant elle pourrait atteindre
insuffisante pour rappel en l'absence
d'intervention on estime que harper est
entre 2 et 3 malheureusement il est
extrêmement difficile d'estimer l'impact
de ses interventions sur arte cependant
en ajustant les paramètres d'un modèle
épidémiologique visant à expliquer lé
nombre de décès dans des pays européens
au cours du dernier mois
cette étude de lyme perial college
suggère que même des mesures plus fortes
encore comme l'interdiction des
événements publics et la fermeture des
écoles même combiné aux gestes barrières
et à la distanciation sociales ont été
très insuffisantes pour ramener rt en
dessous de 1
même des pieds avec des mesures bien
plus forte encore et avec des
populations pourtant très disciplinés
comme par exemple la corée du sud ou
singapour semble avoir un mal fou à
garder leur rt en dessous de 1
ça m'a ainsi foutu un énorme coup au
moral quand j'ai découvert que singapour
a finalement dû imposer à son tour un
confit
sachant cela il semble improbable que la
distanciation sociale les gestes
barrière et le port de masques suffiront
à retrouver une vie normale tout en
garantissant perte est inférieure à 1
si on se contente de cela alors on se
dirige probablement vers un second
confinement avec toutes les conséquences
indésirables voire très indésirable qui
s'ensuivent
pour comprendre ce qui a une chance de
réduire suffisamment rt fruits blue en
douane le dieu de la vulgarisation
mathématiques s'est amusé à lancer de
nombreuses de simulation il faut bien
sûr prendre les résultats de fribourg en
born avec d'énormes pincettes vu qu'il
s'agit de modélisation extrêmement
grossière de ce qui se passe en pratique
néanmoins ces simulations illustrent
quelques effets contre intuitif de la
propagation des épidémies et vous pouvez
d'ailleurs vous même lancer vos propres
simulations facilement et ajuster les
paramètres vous même en allant sur cette
superbe page web de prat joêl sousa
fort de ces simulations tribout endroit
nous propose 5 constatations la première
est l'importance de la distanciation
sociales et des gestes barrières pour
réduire rt et l'effet monumental qu'une
réduction de rt assure la propagation de
l'épidémie
puis blue engone mentionne aussi la
durée de la maladie malheureusement sa
faute de vaccins on ne peut pas y faire
grand chose
cependant la troisième constatation que
fribourg noires portent sur les limites
de la distanciation sociale bien sûr si
elle est appliquée à 100 % elle est
extrêmement efficace mais de petites
imperfections dans cette distanciation
sociale même hauteur de 10 % semble
suffire à propager le virus à une grosse
proportion de la population l'avantagent
important toutefois de cette
distanciation social c'est que même
imparfaite
elle permet grandement d'aplatir la
courbe est donc d'éviter une surcharge
hospitalière de façon plus préoccupante
la cinquième constatation de fribourg en
douane porte sur le fait que en présence
de lieux à forte affluence comme des
marchés des universités ou des gares la
distanciation social un effet limité
selon les simulations de fribourg en
branle réduire l'affluence de tels lieux
d'un facteur 5 est équivalent à réduire
la probabilité d'infection d'un facteur
2 ce qu'on peut peut-être espérer plus
raisonnablement en insistant beaucoup
par exemple sur les gestes barrières et
l'hygiène few words borgne a aussi à
étudier une forme radicale de
distanciation social savoir la fermeture
des frontières
malheureusement dans ces situations il
constate que la fermeture des frontières
à 98% un effet limité lorsque la
pandémie est déjà trop avancé
ceci dit ces mesures peuvent sauver des
régions si elles sont appliquées alors
que le virus est déjà bien contenu ce
qu'on peut peut-être espérer constaté
avant le déconfinement enfin et surtout
la deuxième constatation de fribourg en
bonne porte sur l'importance de
l'isolation d'une très grande proportion
des infectés et en particulier les
crucial de faire attention aux délais
que nous autres humains auront entre le
moment où on a les premiers symptômes et
le moment où nous nous mettons en
quarantaine si nous attendons les
résultats d'un test pour choisir de nous
mettre en quarantaine
il sera sans doute trop tard la
probabilité d'avoir transmis le virus
entre temps pourrait être trop grande
ceci dit de façon intrigante détecter et
confiner les personnes infectées assez
vite demeure très efficace ni compris en
cas de lieux à forte affluence
voilà qui donne de l'espoir à la
réouverture des gares et à la
circulation de davantage de citoyens
pour cela il semble crucial de mettre en
place un dispositif pour identifier les
personnes infectées et garantir leur
mise en quarantaine
le cas du coc vide 19 il y à un autre
facteur aggravant qui n'a pas été prise
en compte dans les simulations de
fribourg doit en fait le gros problème
du comité 19
c'est que certaines contaminations sont
probablement prêt symptomatique c'est à
dire qu'un individu infecté va
contaminer une personne saine alors que
l'individu infecté n'a pas encore de
symptômes
ainsi même si on teste on met en
quarantaine tous ceux qui présentent des
symptômes on n'aura absolument pas
résolu le cas de contamination très
symptomatique pour savoir s'il nous faut
déployer d intervention pour empêcher
les contaminations très symptomatique
il est très important de déterminer si
ces contaminations représentent une part
importante de toutes les contaminations
si finalement très peu de contamination
sont très symptomatique
alors peut-être que lutter contre est un
gaspillage de ressources qu'en est il
donc
pourra-t-on déployer des interventions
contraignantes pour lutter contre les
contaminations près symptomatique
c'est précisément cette question qu'on
étudiait des chercheurs d'oxford en
grande-bretagne
ils ont étudié différents scénarios de
contamination pour expliquer certaines
données alors honnêtement le biais de
sélection des données et la petite
taille de l'échantillon qui
correspondent à 44 de transmission
seulement rend l'analyse intéressante
mais pas franchement très robuste ceci
dit les chercheurs expliquent que le
résultat semble parfaitement cohérent
avec beaucoup d'observations empiriques
à la fois sur des cas où le virus a été
assez bien contenu comme en chine en
corée du sud ou à singapour et sur des
cas où il a été moins bien contenu comme
en europe
quoi qu'il en soit les résultats de leur
étude tiennent dans ce tableau où il
identifie quatre modes de contamination
différents à savoir les transmissions
près symptomatique poste symptomatique
asymptomatique et environnemental mais
transmission asymptomatiques ce sont les
transmissions par individu porteur sans
symptômes jusque là il semble y avoir
peu d'éléments qui suggèrent de telles
contaminations par ailleurs si le taux
de contamination asymptomatiques était
élevé alors il semblerait très peu
probable que le coc vie de 19 serait
contenue dans des pays comme taiwan et
cette étude d'oxford va aussi dans ce
sens en suggérant qu autour de 6 %
seulement des contaminations sont
asymptomatiques
par la suite je vais considérer que ces
contaminations asymptomatiques sont
négligeables
si ce n'est pas le cas le reste du
discours devra être remis en cause alors
l'hypothèse selon laquelle peu de
transmission sont
symptomatique je parle bien des
transmissions asymptomatique et pas des
cas un synthétique qui eux sont
probablement assez nombreux la
proportion de contamination
asymptomatiques semble être assez faible
si on en croit le discours de certains
épidémiologistes travaux connu comme par
exemple marcel salat et par exemple cet
extrait récente de la méthode
scientifique
cependant on m'a signalé cet article the
british medical journal où on y voit de
données possiblement perturbante la
première viendrait apparemment de
données classifiées en chine apportera
43000 cas de contamination à
saint-thomas tic et la deuxième vient du
cas d'un village dans le nord de
l'italie où la mise en quarantaine de
tous les individus testés positifs au co
vie de 19,1 permis de drastiquement
réduire la propagation de l'épidémie
alors je vous avoir une compréhension
très incomplète de la situation mais il
me semble possible que dans cet article
il n'y a pas de distinction entre les
cas asymptomatiques et les câpres est
symptomatique
ce qui suggèrerait que les cas de
contamination dont cet article parle
poite en fait davantage être des
contaminations près symptomatique
bref l'incertitude à ce sujet semble
encore énorme et il semble utile
d'explorer les deux configurations et de
préparer des réponses dans les deux
configurations c'est à dire si on
suppose que les contaminations
asymptomatiques sont nombreuses ou sinon
suppose que ces contaminations
asymptomatiques sont rares
la faible prévalence des contaminations
asymptomatiques serait en tout cas une
excellente nouvelle ça suggère qu'il
pourrait être possible de contenir la
maladie sans se soucier des
asymptomatiques
ce qui est beaucoup mieux car gérer le
cas de ces asymptomatiques serait
nécessairement très contraignant mieux
encore si jamais on arrive dans les mois
à venir à identifier les traits
physiologiques qui font qu'un individu
sera très probablement asymptomatiques
une fois infecté
alors on pourra lever le confinement
pour ces individus quasiment sans
augmenter rt pour l'instant en tout cas
on en n'est absolument pas là pour
l'instant les données sur les cas
asymptomatiques sont encore très
parcellaires et il faut rester très
prudent il transmission environnementale
elles correspondent à toutes les
surfaces sur lesquelles le virus des
pauses avant d'être possiblement
collectés par la main de quelqu'un là
encore l'étude suggère que ces
transmissions pourrait être faible mais
il faut là il me semble être beaucoup
plus présents que dans le cas des
asymptomatiques en particulier les
intervalles de crédence de l'étude sont
énormes
il ne semble pas y avoir des arguments
très forts pour exclure cette
possibilité
si jamais ces transmissions
environnementales sont beaucoup plus
importantes que suggérée dans l'étude
il faudra absolument prendre soin de
désinfecter régulièrement des objets des
lieux publics que beaucoup de gens
touchent notamment avec les mains comme
les rampes dans les transports publics
les digicodes et les boutons d'ascenseur
il sera également important d'appeler la
population à ne pas toucher inutilement
ces objets public à porter des masques
pour ne pas déposer des virus sur ces
surfaces et à ne pas se toucher le
visage avec les mains
quoi qu'il en soit selon l'étude il
semblerait que les contaminations près
symptomatique joue un rôle aussi
important voire peut-être plus important
encore que les infections symptomatique
même si une fois encore les marges
d'erreur sont très importantes alors à
ce sujet hier il ya eu une nouvelle
publication dans nature médecine qui va
dans le même sens que la publication
d'oxford et estime en particulier que
44% des contaminations sont très
symptomatique
avec encore une fois un intervalle de
crédence assez grand mais cette fois qui
est également un peu moins délirant
encore une fois les données sont un peu
discutable puisque ça correspond à 77
cas de contamination qui ont été en plus
choisis donc il ya un biais de sélection
potentiel n'est au moins dans cet
article il étudie également la charge
virale de différents patients
à partir de l'ordonner ils en ont un
ferrer ce graphe qui est une estimation
du taux de contamination en fonction du
moment où on a les symptômes et comme on
le voit une grande partie des
contaminations semble avoir lieu avant
qu'un individu infecté et le nez ses
premiers symptômes donc typiquement la
timeline ça ressemblerait à ça vous
attraper le virus disons 1 1 10 ensuite
il faudra à peu près deux à trois jours
pour que vous commenciez à être
contagieux du congo le jeudi vous
devenez contagieux puis vous devenez
extrêmement contagieux le vendredi et ce
n'est ensuite que le samedi que vous
commencez à avoir des symptômes ce
moment là vous êtes encore très
contagieux mais très rapidement votre
contagiosité diminue le dimanche le
lundi puis le mardi suivant vous êtes
encore contagieux me voulait être
beaucoup moins et en gros ensuite au
cours de la deuxième semaine
vous perdez petit à petit en
contagiosité alors j'insiste sur le fait
que ceci est le cas moyens mais bien sûr
il ya énormément de variabilité d'une
personne à l'autre
quoi qu'il en soit cette étude suggèrent
fortement que si l'on veut contenir le
coc vite 19
il faut trouver des solutions pour
éviter les contaminations près
symptomatique
pour cela on pourra exiger bien sûr le
confinement de tout individu
cependant comme on l'a vu dans le
dernier épisode en plus d'être très
liberticide et de poser de sérieux
risques de santé mentale cette mesure
semble aussi dangereuse économiquement
et politiquement d'autre solution moins
contraignante semble désirable dès lors
pour réduire significativement les
infections très symptomatique de manière
peu contraignantes pour l'ensemble de la
population
il faut absolument identifier des
individus qui ont une probabilité
importante d'être contagieux sans avoir
observé le fait qu'ils soient
symptomatique et ça bien sûr ce n'est
pas facile
pour mieux comprendre comment tout
dans la propagation du virus on peut
modéliser le taux de reproduction
effectif comme étant une combinaison du
taux de base x les effets des
différentes interventions les gestes
barrière réduisent le taux de
reproduction de manière proportionnelle
ainsi si le port de masques réduit de
20%
les probabilités de contamination lors
d'un contact entre un individu infecté
et un individu sain alors rt sera lui
aussi réduit de 20%
c'est donc très important de faire
attention aux gestes barrière avec les
gestes barrières on passe du taux de
reproduction de base 0,01 à un taux
effectif
rt est égal à zéro point et bt ou gbt l
effet des gestes barrières à l'instant t
qui dans l'exemple que je viens de
donner est égal à 80%
l'immunité de groupe elle aussi va jouer
6 5% de la population a déjà été
infectées il semble qu'elles deviennent
ensuite globalement immunisés même s'il
ya des bémols important à mettre à cela
si c'est le cas ça serait vraiment très
très chouette
bon d'un côté parce que du coup c'est 5%
de la population n'aurait plus rien à
craindre mais aussi et surtout parce
qu'ils vont réduire le taux de
reproduction effectif ainsi seulement 95
% des contacts d'un individu infecté et
non pas 100 % seront désormais des
individus vulnérables aux qu'ovide 19
voilà qui nous fait multiplier rt par un
move axe t'es où vas tu t es la fraction
d'immuniser noter aussi que j'appelle la
fraction d'immuniser vax t car dans le
cas d'autres maladies comme la rougeole
vaccin correspond essentiellement à la
fraction de la population vaccinée
malheureusement comme on en a parlé dans
la vidéo précédente dans le cas du
comité 19
on ne dispose malheureusement pas de
vaccin et on n'en disposera probablement
pas d'ici au moins un an
alors sans vaccin à l'immunité de groupe
va quand même jouer un rôle dans la
réduction de rt mais à moins que 20 % ou
50 % de la population soit immunisée cet
effet de limiter deux groupes ne va pas
en fait changer grand chose à la valeur
de rt d'autant que si on rentre plus
dans les détails il faudrait écarter les
asymptomatique et ainsi uniquement
considéré la fraction de la population
immunisés parmi ceux qui ne seront pas
un symptomatique
notez aussi que des tests appelé
sérologique pourrait également nous
aider à mieux identifier les personnes
immunisées contre locaux vides 19
cependant il ya d'énormes bémol à mettre
aux tests sérologiques dont j'ai parlé
notamment dans ceux fred et au sujet
duquel
ce qui semble préparer une vidéo en
attendant voici un extrait d'une vieille
vidéo de monsieur fille où il parle
exactement de ce problème mais pour une
maladie hypothétique qu'il appelle la
schtroumpf 8
donc même en étant testé positivement à
ce test fiable à 99 %
vous ne devriez vraiment pas parié sur
le fait que vous êtes malade vous avez
en fait moins de 10% de chances de
l'être
c'est vrai que c'est frappant
enfin il ya les interventions
individus prêts symptomatique les
individus poste symptomatique et sur
l'environnement par exemple on
désinfectant régulièrement nos
téléphones
nos bureaux et les objets public là ce
qui est crucial de voix c'est que les
interventions sur disons les individus
poste automatique ne vont pas
directement changer rt ou du moins pas
proportionnellement
oui car seulement une fraction des
contaminations que je vais appeler ici
alpha poste son poste symptomatique
en fait chaque intervention sur chaque
type de contamination va avoir un poids
qui correspond à la fraction de
contamination associés à ce type c'est
pour ça que les critiques de comprendre
la prévalence des différents types de
contamination
si l'on en croit l'article d'oxford 50%
des contaminations seraient ainsi prêts
symptomatique donc alpha prêt est à peu
près égale à 0,5
les contaminations poste automatique et
environnemental représenterait 40 % et
10 % des contaminations ou alpha poste
est à peu près de l'ordre de 0,4 et
alpha en environ 0,1 en appelant qu tes
posts la réduction relative à la
contamination des individus poste
symptomatique grâce aux interventions à
l'instant t or gestes barrières et de
même qu tu es prêt à écouter en les
impacts ses interventions sur les
contaminations très symptomatique et
environnemental on obtient alors
l'équation fondamentale qui régit le
taux de reproduction effectif
rt cette équation dit que rt est égal au
taux de base réduit proportionnellement
grâce aux interventions sur les gestes
barrières réduit ensuite
proportionnellement par l'immunité de
groupe d'un facteur 1 - vaccin est
réduit ensuite par les interventions sur
les différents types de contamination
qui ne correspondent pas à des gestes
barrières la désinfection des objets
semblent alors joué un rôle mais pas du
tout aussi important que la mise en
quarantaine des individus symptomatique
ainsi que si on arrive à complètement
annulé les contamination
environnementale
alors on aura réduit rt que de 10 %
seulement al'inverse la mise en
quarantaine des individus poste
symptomatique aurait un effet important
en supposant que la quarantaine
réduisent de 60% les contaminations
poste symptomatique ce qui revient à
avoir quitté poste égal à 0 4 on aurait
alors une réduction de rt de 24 % ce qui
est beaucoup plus alors c'est beaucoup
plus
merci avant de prendre cette mesure on
avait rt qui était de l'ordre de 2 qui
sont loin d'être farfelue vu les
estimations qu'on a jusque là alors la
mise en
quarantaine des postes symptomatique
seraient insuffisantes pour ramener rt
en dessous de 1
même combiné à une désinfection des
objets public
ceci pourrait être très insuffisant en
fait la mise en quarantaine des
individus infectés et pressante
automatique serait alors extrêmement
importante
si comme la quarantaine des postes
symptomatique la quarantaine des prêts
symptomatique réduite 60% leur
contamination très symptomatique
c'est à dire si q tu es prêt est de
l'ordre de 43 cents alors cette
intervention sur les prés symptomatique
réduit et rt de 30%
voilà qui serait un effet additionnel
très important en fait si arte est égal
à 200 quarantaine alors ce n'est qu'en
combinant la quarantaine des prêts et
des postes symptomatique on pourrait
alors faire passer arte en dessous de 1
selon notre modèle simplifié avec ses
deux interventions on aurait ainsi perte
est de l'ordre de 0,92 en y rajoutant
une désinfection des objets public qui
divise par deux les contamination
environnementale
on pourrait même avoir rt de l'ordre de
0.82 ce qui est beaucoup plus robuste
mans en dessous de 1 et pourrait donc
même être robuste a par exemple une
baisse de garde des gestes barrières
alors bien sûr tout ça ne s'agit que
d'estimations très grossière qui
s'appuie sur estimations discutable arte
est de l'ordre de 2 en l'absence de
quarantaine mais avec tous les gestes
barrières on peut en particulier se
demander si ces estimations ne serait
pas trop pessimiste
même si on n'arrive pas à agir sur les
infectés presse automatique
alors nos interventions sont peut-être
déjà suffisante pour amener arte en
dessous de 1 et éviter un second
confinement avec toutes les conséquences
potentiellement catastrophiques qui
l'accompagnent malheureusement l exemple
de sainghin pouvoir suggère que même
avec des interventions strictes on peut
avoir rt plus grand que 1 malgré une
vigilance extrême et des interventions
sur les gestes barrières est
symptomatique et l'environnement
singapour n'a pas réussi à suffisamment
contenir locaux vides 19 et a dû imposer
à son tour un confinement
or probablement qu'en europe on
n'arrivera pas à faire mieux au niveau
des gestes barrières des interventions
sur l'environnement et des interventions
sur les infectés poste symptomatique
qu'à singapour
est-ce qu'on est donc foutu et vous et
un second confinement dévastateur pour
notre économie
eh bien peut-être pas il reste peut-être
espoirs concernant les infections près
symptomatique
il semble largement possible de déployer
des meilleures interventions sur les
prés symptomatique que ce qui a été fait
à singapour
en fait si singapour n'a pas réussi à
contenir la pandémie
c'est probablement parce qu'ils n'ont
pas réussi à combattre efficacement les
infections près symptomatique
oui car en particulier le contact racing
n'a été déployés là-bas que très
tardivement et son taux d'utilisation
n'était que de 16 % seulement
alors le contact racing c'est quoi alors
pour commencer
ce n'est absolument pas apprécié
prérévolutionnaire le nom peut faire
peur mais le contact racing est
appliquée en temps normal pour mieux
limiter la propagation des épidémies
l'idée c'est qu'un individu récemment
infectés informent les autorités
sanitaires des personnes avec lesquelles
l'individu infecté est entré en contact
grâce à ces informations les autorités
sanitaires pourront identifier tous les
cas suspects les tester et les mettre en
quarantaine si besoin est le problème
toutefois c'est que ce processus est
long coûteux et imprécis ça peut prendre
de nombreux jours pour contacter toutes
les bonnes personnes
ça coûte beaucoup de temps de travail
aux autorités sanitaires déjà débordé
surtout s'il ya des milliers de nouveaux
cas par jour et surtout c'est imprécis
parce que nous autres humains avant une
très mauvaise mémoire l'idée du contact
racing électronique c'est de faire faire
ce travail par nos téléphones pour que
ce soit rapide pour que ça ne coûte rien
et pour que surtout ça n'oublie rien on
l'a vu les imperfections dans la mise en
quarantaine peuvent coûter très cher
alors il ya beaucoup de propositions de
contact racing avec toutes sortes de
variantes sur quelles informations sont
partagées avec qui avec l chiffrement et
avec quelle responsabilité individuelle
en particulier certaines propositions
sont beaucoup moins invasive que
d'autres mais repose beaucoup plus sur
la responsabilité de chaque personne à
risque ce qui pourrait réduire l'impact
du contact racing sur le taux de
reproduction effective le spectre du
design va ainsi de dp3 tu es un projet
européen ultra prévisible priseur ving
porté notamment par beaucoup
d'informaticiens de le pfl ou en
université en suisse à une surveillance
extrême en chine où la température
corporelle de livreur de colis et
partager publiquement dans la prochaine
vidéo que je sortirai dès que possible
je détaillerai les aspects techniques et
légaux du contact racing et en
particulier de dp3 t j'essaierai de vous
expliquer en quoi dp3 t est
effectivement ultra privacy priseur ving
quelles que soient les détails de la
solution technique il s'agira au final
d'une application à installer sur nos
téléphones qui collectera des données en
continu de façon entièrement chiffrée ou
non en particulier l'application
collectera des données sur la proximité
physique entre deux téléphones soit en
mesurant leurs coordonnées gps ce qui
pourrait permettre aussi d'identifier en
temps réel des zones à risque soient en
mesure en des signaux plus tous le gros
avantage du bluetooth
c'est que d'un point de vue privacy
c'est beaucoup beaucoup mieux
les données peuvent ainsi être stocké
uniquement dans nos téléphones ne jamais
transité via internet
modulo quelques détails pour lister les
identifiants des personnes infectées
c'est en tout cas la solution
privilégiée par dp 3 t quoi qu'il en
soit étant donné ces données
l'application notifierait ensuite
l'utilisateur si parmi les gens avec qui
l'utilisateur est entré en contact il y
à un cas de kobe des 19 confirmé
l'utilisateur pourrait ainsi décider de
se faire tester à son tour et slash ou
de se mettre en quarantaine
voilà qui pourrait permettre de contenir
la pandémie sans nécessiter de
confinement généralisée
cependant pour que ceci est une chance
de
thione il faut absolument que le contact
racing soit adoptée de manière massive
en effet il y aura une différence énorme
entre une utilisation à 16%
comme ce fut le cas à singapour et une
utilisation à 64%
la différence ne serait pas deux fois 4
elle serait deux fois 16
je m'explique pour que le contact le
tracing fonctionne il faut que lors d'un
contact à la fois la personne infectée
et la personne susceptible d'être
infecté disposent tous deux de
l'application pour que l'interaction
soit noté si seulement 16% de la
population utilise l'application alors
lors d'un tel contact en gros
l'interaction aura été enregistrés dans
16% au carré des cas soit 2,5 pour cent
autrement dit lorsque l'application est
utilisé à 16% -2 3% des interactions
pourront être utilisés par le contact
tracing ou dit autrement tant 97% des
cas où une personne est infectée
un individu susceptible qui a été en
contact avec la personne infectée ne le
saura pas l'effet du contact racing
serait alors à peine perceptible pour
que le contrat avec tracy soit efficace
il faut alors absolument qu'il soit
beaucoup plus massivement utilisé avec
64 % d'utilisation 40% des interactions
serait ainsi enregistrer ce qui
permettrait la mise en quarantaine de 40
% des personnes ayant été en contact
avec une personne testée positive ou que
vides 19 voilà qui fait une très grande
différence et on pourra alors peut être
espérer que les contaminations près
symptomatique seront réduits de 30%
autrement dit on pourra alors à espérer
avoir coûté près de l'ordre de 70% en
pratique seulement 80 % des français ont
un smartphone
il sera donc très difficile d'avoir un
taux d'utilisation supérieur à 60 4%
néanmoins tous les coins de france n'ont
pas nécessairement le même besoin en
contact racing typiquement région
parisienne il pourrait être
particulièrement critique d'atteindre un
taux d'utilisation particulièrement
élevé car on y trouve beaucoup de
contacts entre des inconnus notamment
dans les transports en commun al'inverse
toutefois il semble critique que
l'application soit particulièrement
utilisé par des individus qui ont plus
de chances d'être infectés en effet rt
est une moyenne sur l'ensemble des
individus infectés et des contacts des
individus infectés pour que arte diminue
il faut absolument que ces individus
infectés et les contacts de ces
individus
infectés utilisent massivement
l'application malheureusement surtout si
l'application n'est pas obligatoire si
sa promotion n'est fait qu auprès
d'individus déjà très prudents vis-à-vis
du coc vite 19 alors le contact racing
pourrait être inefficace si on veut
espérer ramener rt en dessous de 1
grâce aux contacts tracing surtout en
l'absence de réglementation il va être
critique de déployer une communication
d'excellente qualité à son sujet à la
fois claire pédagogique et convaincante
en particulier même s'il faut bien sûr
être nuancée et prêter super attention
aux risques de surveillance de masse
aussi il me semble surtout crucial de
désapprouvant entouré le contact racing
une connotation positive si même à
singapour le taux d'adoption n'a été que
de 16%
il va falloir une communication
extrêmement favorable contact racing si
on veut avoir une chance d'autoriser à
nouveau la liberté de circulation à une
grande partie de la population de
manière durable et sécurisé et même en
l'absence de solution définitive ou de
consensus dès à présent sur quelle
application promouvoir utilisé il semble
crucial de préparer toute la population
pour qu'elle soit prête à adopter
massivement les applications de contact
racing qui seront choisis par les
services sanitaires en partenariat avec
les agences de sécurité informatique
comme la cnil comme l'affirment
l'organisation mondiale de la santé le
contact racing fait partie de la colonne
vertébrale d'une réponse adéquate à la
pandémie actuelle mais son efficacité
dépend fortement de son adoption massive
par les populations à travers le globe
le futur de la santé publique mais aussi
de notre économie et de notre bien-être
à moyen terme en dépend
jusque là tout ce qu'on a présenté
correspond à une population relativement
discipline et qui fait ce qu'on lui
demande de faire a au moins 90%
cependant en pratique surtout en france
il semble qu'il faille craindre que ces
mesures très contraignantes ne soit pas
suffisamment appliquée par la population
surtout si elle ne comprend pas
suffisamment les enjeux or on a vu
notamment dans les simulations de
fribourg noir que des manquements de 10%
à l'une des interventions pouvait
suffire à transformer une épidémie
contrôlé en pandémie incontrôlée c'est
pourquoi il semble crucial de garantir
que les interventions seront
suffisamment efficace est suivi par la
population en particulier il semble
important que au moins les personnes
testées positives au co vite 19 reste
vraiment chez elle si possible en
quarantaine le pays qui semble être
parvenu le mieux à faire cela semble
être taïwan
la stratégie de taiwan est vraiment
intéressante ils méritaient vraiment
d'être étudiée même si beaucoup de cette
stratégie ne pourront pas d'être
importée en europe pour des raisons de
préférence et éthiques
je vous renvoie notamment vers cette
vidéo de blank pour plus de détails qui
insiste sur des mesures tout à fait un
portable notamment l'attention
bienveillante envers les personnes en
quarantaine les cliniques comédie 19
séparer des hôpitaux et l'investissement
massif dans la communication
scientifique musulman a aussi parlé
d'une mesure plus difficilement un
portable à savoir la notion de clôture
électronique en plus de prendre soin des
individus en quarantaine taiwan fait
aussi attention à ce que les individus
en quarantaine resteront chez eux des
méthodes très invasive sont ainsi
utilisées en vérifiant que le téléphone
d'un individu en quarantaine ne quittera
pas son logement
plus radical encore des mesures sont
prises pour vérifier que l'individu
n'est pas parti se balader sans son
téléphone par exemple en appelant le
téléphone quand celui-ci n'a pas bougé
depuis un moment
alors oui tout ça c'est ultra crépy et
j'aimerais vraiment qu'on n'ait pas
besoin d'en arriver là
cependant c'est la liberté de l'ensemble
de notre société avec tous les risques
associés à un confinement global dont
j'ai déjà parlé
si tout ceci est menacée par un ensemble
d'individus qui ne respectent pas les
consignes sanitaires
il y a un sacré dilemme éthique qui se
posent d'un point de vue moral
ne serait-il pas souhaitable de
contraindre davantage cet ensemble
d'individus pour le bien et la sécurité
du plus grand nombre
je comprends tout à fait qu'on trouve
cette surveillance massive extrêmement
indésirables
mais ce n'est pas la question il n'y
aura pas de solution parfaite pour que
les mois à venir soit garantie de ne pas
conduire à une catastrophe
la question est plus celle de trouver un
compromis entre différents mots ni
attire alors pas au moins un compromis
qui pourrait être trouvée ici entre u2
prévu si imparfaite et la sécurité
nationale
voilà ça
beaucoup de choses à digérer en peu de
temps et j'ai sans doute dit beaucoup de
bêtises
aujourd'hui malheureusement cette
période de crise il se passe énormément
de choses et il ya énormément nombre
d'interactions complexes entre toutes
sortes de disciplines comme la virologie
la chimie la logistique la finance
l'économie la politique l'informatique
la psychologie l'épistémologie la
philosophe film aura le droit et les
mathématiques
or personne je dis bien personne ne
maîtrise ne serait-ce qu'une fraction de
tout ce qu'il faudrait envisager pour
comprendre au mieux la situation
actuelle dans ce contexte vu
l'incertitude énorme vis-à-vis du futur
il semble critique de mesurer l'étendue
de notre ignorance et d'adopter le
safety mindset c'est-à-dire l'habitude
d'envisager les pires cas pour éviter
les catastrophes
or à ce stade de la pandémie les pires
cas ne semble ni improbable ni rassurant
même si j'espère tellement me tromper
ceci devrait énormément affecté vos
balance coûts bénéfices dès lors il
semble urgent de moins envisagés et
préparer les interventions les plus
radicales pour éviter autant que
possible que des tragédies monumental
n'arrive
parmi elles il semble que celles qui
visent à réduire drastiquement le taux
de reproduction est effectif
rt sont particulièrement importantes le
contact racing combiner un dépistage
massif semble une des approches les plus
prometteuses et son implémentation par
l'application des pétro a été proposée
par des chercheurs à travers l'europe en
particulier le pfl présente un compromis
particulièrement intéressant entre
efficacité et protection des données
personnelles
il me semble urgent pour le futur de
l'humanité que cette solution soit
massivement promu pour qu'elles soient
ensuite massivement adopté néanmoins
même si le contact tracing fonctionne à
merveille
il semble utile de moins envisagés le
cas où il serait insuffisant
d'autres solutions plus invasive et
contraignantes devrait alors peut-être
être envisagée est préparé quitte à ne
pas les utiliser si on constate que la
pandémie est effectivement sous contrôle
se préparer au pire qu'à futur ça
correspond à déployer des moyens qui ne
seront probablement pas utiliser de
façon plus générale il ya
malheureusement beaucoup d'autres choses
encore à comprendre notamment d'un point
de vue technique pour mieux discerner
les difficultés technologiques
légal et épidémiologiques qui entoure
ces solutions tel sera le sujet de la
prochaine vidéo de cette série
exceptionnelle